vous Yves alors vous on vous imaginez
milliardaire le mec il a mangé
deux alors maintenant
voilà le dernier est en vente le dernier
Vandal c'est lequel le dernier c'est pas
l'Ardèche je leur ai dit
près d'Angoulême le magnifique alors là
vous arrivez sur la route oui un château
là haut
mais j'ai pas dormi on pouvait pas
dormir toute façon on pouvait pas dormir
dans celui-là si bah maintenant il y a
des chambres de quoi alors quelle idée
je sais que tu as toujours aimé les
antiquités les choses anciennes parce
que toi-même tu es antiquaire aussi à ta
façon la grand-mère
quand j'ai dit les antiquités vous êtes
gentil
et alors cette passion de des choses
anciennes de l'antiquité de l'art etc
c'est ça qui t'a poussé à acheter des
châteaux comme ça
parce que au départ je cherchais une
ferme figure toi quand j'ai eu gagne un
peu d'argent avec le métier je me suis
dit j'ai trouvé une ferme en Normandie
puisque je suis normalement d'origine et
pas moyen de trouver pour le budget que
j'avais une ferme c'était trop cher donc
je me suis rabattu sur un château en
Picardie le château me demander à
l'époque 300000 300000 francs donc avec
300000 francs j'ai trouvé un manoir un
petit manoir joli
qui était en Picardie mais je pouvais
pas tu la ferme donc le manoir ça a été
mon premier château et après ça on m'a
dit tiens il y a celui-là qui est à
vendre alors j'ai dit bonjour ça c'est
Suzanne donc j'ai appelé j'ai appelé
Jean-Jacques Debout j'ai dit est-ce que
tu veux pas un beau château parce que
moi pour moi c'était énorme c'était
énorme je suis allé là le voir et là je
suis tombé à genoux devant la beauté du
site
alors le la devise du château c'était où
la Crète donc je te dis c'est pour moi
et donc j'ai acheté et puis voilà un
moment ou un autre on m'a dit ben
écoutez monsieur Lecoq on va vous
demander tant d'argent parce que j'ai
pas payé tant d'impôts et donc je suis
parti j'ai vendu bon alors donc bon il y
a eu d'autres châteaux évidemment on va
pas tous ces énumérer il y en a eu pas
mal mais dans ces cas-là c'est vrai
est-ce qu'il y a une défiscalisation
mais si c'est déjà pas l'intérêt comme
je gagnais bien ma vie quand même avec
tout ce que je faisais défiscaliser tout
passait dans les travaux tout mais
j'avais pas un sou de côté mais la
drague d'ailleurs j'aurais pu mettre
quand même 500 balles de côté pour avoir
au moins une un peu d'argent quand j'ai
des problèmes sont peut-être obligés de
te taper 500
en tout cas voilà
c'était gentil bon bref donc tout ça
c'était parti là-bas c'est parti là-bas
et effectivement du coup ben les impôts
c'était absorbés par les monuments
historiques par les travaux que je
faisais alors toi tu as pas peur de
parler d'argent comme ça parce que c'est
quand même très bien mais tous ces
châteaux maintenant donc il en reste
plus que deux tu me dis et mettez encore
des dettes oui j'ai encore des dettes
parce qu'il faut vraiment que je vende
comme j'ai tout vendu à bas prix non
mais il va bien elle vient du fait que
j'ai tout vendu à bas prix c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu le la covid oui mais parce
que c'était l'urgence de vendre c'est
pour ça que
aux enchères mais en 24 heures enfin les
je trouve l'argent donc le sol qui a pu
pourquoi tu payes pas l'URSSAF tu payes
pas ce que tu devais payer non mais oui
j'avais des dettes qui étaient pas
énormes puis bon il y avait toujours ça
se réduisait quand je vendait un truc on
me donnait toujours moins que prévu donc
je vends des tours à baies et voilà donc
à un moment il manquait de l'argent
c'est tout et c'est pas des sommes
énormes mais pour être tranquille il
faut que je vende celui-là voilà le
dernier
alors les chansons étaient spectacles et
ça te rapporte de l'argent là toujours
maintenant ah oui mais moi j'ai arrêté
le spectacle avec la covid il y a 3 ans
donc j'ai arrêté d'un seul coup la télé
ouais tout d'un coup s'il vous plaît non
vous ça marche trop bien aussi c'est
dehors du jour au lendemain
ensuite j'ai arrêté bah le spectacle à
cause covid et j'ai arrêté ben qu'est-ce
qui t'arrête pas canal voilà donc
oui je suis à la retraite mais je
travaille quand même
Sarkozy on a le droit de travailler donc
c'est que là je viens de refaire
du futur sympathique c'est quelqu'un de
refaire un store de de showcase dans mon
village j'ai fait un spectacle qui était
filmé et donc avec ça je vais envoyer à
tous les producteurs qui me réclament ma
présence sur scène et je vais repartir
en gala mais bien sûr parce que
ça fait pile poil 50 il faudra
réactualiser certaines voix on a la
chance de d'accueillir Stone vraiment
c'est un bonheur Stone de te voir tu es
en pleine forme tu es très belle
franchement alors tu vois quand on parle
comme ça toi je crois que tu es assez
libre aussi ouverte pour parler de ça
comment ça se passe pour toi Stone ah
ben moi bien mais j'ai une retraite
ridicule mais bon bah on fait avec comme
on disait l'avantage qu'on a c'est qu'on
peut quand même continuer à faire des
spectacles à gagner voilà moi en plus je
sors des livres régulièrement donc je
fais beaucoup de salon du livre de
dédicaces donc aussi voilà c'est aussi
une façon de gagner sa vie et ça se
passe bien quoi et puis j'ai on a
l'avantage aussi d'avoir investi autant
de notre
splendeur dans des appartements donc ça
c'est chez nous une maison
dis-moi moi je me plains pas du tout
loin
de s'accueillir en plus pour cela mais
toi tous les tubes tous les tubes que
tout le monde connaît de Stone on se
demande toujours doit toucher encore là
dessus
qu'interprète ça change tout je me suis
ni auteur ni compositeur
qui c'est toujours un peu voilà limité
quand on est que interprète bien sûr
voilà de l'époque si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à Annie et Eric
qui m'a dit oui pardon donc Stone
donc Peter eux m'ont découvert au
cabaret il y a 50 ans et donc ils m'ont
pris à l'Olympia direct et du jour au
lendemain Guy Luke et compagnie je suis
devenu grâce à eux donc voilà
Éric Annie
alors je voulais c'est ce qu'on parle
des célébrités qui évoquent l'argent
évidemment il y a notamment notre
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire
qui a évoqué son salaire
parce que voilà c'est très sympa et tout
ça mais il faut se rendre compte quand
même se rendre compte que la France
crève la dalle là on parle il parle
quand même non mais moi je suis pas du
tout voilà je vous dis vraiment ce que
je pense ça me dérange d'entendre que
quelqu'un dit qu'il gagne 7000 ou 10000
ou 15000 euros et qui dit oui c'est
compliqué machin parce que on peut pas
dire que c'est compliqué à un moment
donné faut aller dans la rue faut voir
elle lui a posé la question
de répondre à la question mais c'est le
cacher c'est le cacher des ministres
c'est pas lui qui me choque le plus mais
parce que on parlait des célébrités qui
parlent d'argent moi je trouve que c'est
pas nécessaire parce que c'était le
débat et c'est la question que vous nous
avez posé à la base moi je trouve que
c'est pas la peine d'exposer ce que tu
gagnes parce que moi ça me dérange
pas
simplement d'avoir une certaine pudeur
par rapport comme ça parce que attention
enfin voilà quand tu sors dehors et même
enfin faut se rendre compte de ce que
les gens vivent donc faut pas être
hors-sol parce que sinon voilà
Jean-Michel je trouve ça mauvais procès
qu'on fait au politique parce que c'est
les hommes ils sont tous ils sont tous
très intelligents supplément intelligent
c'est les machines intellectuelles ils
auraient fait beaucoup plus d'argent
dans le privé en étant avocat d'affaires
en travaillant dans des fonds
d'investissement qu'en étant politique
ça ça donne ils ont donc c'est pas pour
l'argent qu'ils ont fait une politique
donc on peut pas le reprocher de gagner
7400 si j'étais avocat homme d'affaires
ils gagneraient beaucoup beaucoup plus
c'est vrai alors justement
vous allez réagir à ça quand Virginie
Efira dit qu'effectivement 100000 euros
c'est assez choquant pour faire lol etc
vous qu'est-ce que vous en pensez bah
les artistes ont l'air qui gagne de
l'argent je veux dire on a su panier
avait gagné beaucoup d'argent aussi bon
et d'accord il est pas avec le fils mais
bon il a toujours dit quoi et là à la
limite on lui pardonne parce que une
star bah ça gagne à une star du foot
alors on en parlons pas tous les mettre
au pilori et oui ça choquait pas Johnny
quand par exemple Johnny qui reste
toujours l'icône toutes ces maisons de
Johnny les dépenses les les les les
crimes j'étais
il y a la crise je veux dire là on est
quand même dans une France qui souffre
de ça tu sais quand on touche par
exemple tu fais une émission ça dure une
journée de tournage 100000 balles 200000
balles on a évoqué des sommes
considérables blanche Gardin ça
scandaleux
parce que moi jamais j'ai touchée
pourquoi que ce soit quand on faisait
des gala bon ce que tu as fait
raisonnable quelque part il y avait rien
de 32 extraordinaire quoi
parce qu'il faut il faut savoir quand
même 7 attendez ce qu'il faut savoir
quand même c'est que quand les chanteurs
je disais tout à l'heure avant que vous
arriviez tous les chanteurs ils sortent
ils disent etc ça l'album ça marche très
bien mais là où il gagne le plus
d'argent c'est en concert c'est en tout
cas vous gagnez de l'argent et alors
Stonne toi récemment d'ailleurs tu as
confié le montant de ta retraite oui moi
j'ai une retraite très limitée un petit
peu un peu plus de 1000 euros bon bah
voilà mais comme je disais tout à
l'heure je compte pas que là-dessus quoi
il y a autre d'autres apports d'argent
qui sont bienvenus bien sûr et ça permet
en même temps de se bouger un peu de se
dire bon à pas je me repose pas sur mes
lauriers j'ai encore des choses à
défendre des choses en plus qui sont
passionnantes alors donc allons-y
Isabelle il faut arrêter de comparer ce
qui est pas comparable toi tu gagnes par
exemple peut-être beaucoup d'argent mais
tu réalises
[Rires]
Johnny il pouvait pas s'arrêter il était
classique et réinvestissait dans des
spectacles le constamment
il faut avoir des liquidités s'il te
plaît liquidités je pense que c'était le
cas de Yves il a pas pu conserver en
fait ces châteaux parce qu'il a besoin
d'une pour vivre tous les jours quand tu
vas dans un château tu prends une
polémique
tu veux répondre à quoi
oufs
jamais palpé vraiment puisque tout
partait systématiquement dans ce de
cette défense du patrimoine parce que
les châteaux que j'ai restauré bah ils
sont debout maintenant c'était des
ruines donc je suis parti à zéro
l'Ardèche c'était une carcasse j'en ai
fait un château
comme ça aussi il y a des aides et des
temps
ça c'est une vraie passion pour passer
ton bonheur aussi et c'est vrai que et
en même temps c'était la logique c'est à
dire que je me disais bon si j'ai fini
tel château je croyais l'avoir fini
c'était jamais fini mais si j'ai fini on
en propose un autre j'hésite mais je
reprends parce que c'est voilà je suis
tenté par le fait la reprise
il faut te fermer oui malade comme lui
de quoi
c'est pas la peine en revanche moi il y
a un truc vraiment qui me choque
beaucoup pardon Francesca j'écoute tout
ton discours il est parfaitement
recevable mais ceux qui sont qui
pourraient être le plus critiquer c'est
justement le monde du football
que tu as toujours défendu alors là là
on est sur totalement autre chose ben
oui totalement autre chose parce que
ramène des milliards et des milliards
ça brille et des châteaux encore debout
grâce à lui c'est le patrimoine Yves
Lecoq c'est le patrimoine pas lui mais
le château
j'ai sauvé le château je suis un dieu
vivant parce que j'aurais sauvé dans le
château aussi c'était énorme moment donc
c'était du mécénat c'était pas pour moi
et c'est ça qu'il faut dire il veut pas
choquer les téléspectateurs
effectivement on se dit ouais il veut
quoi qu'il est gentil il a des châteaux
incroyables
monsieur Niel maintenant
c'est
là que j'ai dormi moi une fois
[Applaudissements]
vraiment j'ai dormi tout seul c'était
lors du festival tu sais de tous les
Angoulême du film et il m'envoie de là
tout seul tout seul
je suis rentré là-dedans
[Rires]
une trouille
j'ai pris une chambre qu'on m'avait il y
avait quelqu'un qui fait mon lit et j'ai
vu personne j'ai vu des gens que le
matin au petit déj et je vous raconte ça
c'est intéressant il y a personne enfin
il y a un gardien mais il est à côté ah
il est à côté
donc je me suis démerdé à rentrer le
truc était incroyable non mais je
t'assure c'est vraiment un vieux truc et
le plancher craque et après une fois que
tu as marché il continue de craquer
encore
une angoisse non mais rigole pas une
angoisse je te l'avais dit une trouille
j'ai rien j'ai
avec tes cambrioleurs autour du bois
j'en sais rien mais je ils sont protégés
quand même quoi en tout cas bravo c'est
ce que je voulais dire c'est ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'en tout cas Yves
il a consacré tout son pognon a
réhabiliter tous ces châteaux et ça
c'est bravo pour le patrimoine déjà on
peut l'applaudir parce que c'est
magnifique
solo alors l'aventure c'est quoi Stone
l'aventure c'est quoi c'est-à-dire
avec toi
[Musique]
ma copine en tout cas personne merci
beaucoup un petit détail je continue de
chanter avec mon fils
junior
bravo Baptiste Charden et un métier mais
il adore chanter et on fait beaucoup de
gala ensemble bravo
[Applaudissements]